I would say that you are extremely
emotional do you consider yourself an
emotional male not really I would say I
do a good job of you know controlling
them okay these two in caner try to
destroy us guess what happens we became
even stronger from that I'm like
yes you can stop being
a man because you have the fierce
tenacity that no one
can a little sick today so I might sound
a little weird seems that myON really
wants to get physical with me and Andrew
Schultz if you aren't aware um DJ
academics went on the flagrant podcast
and fresh and fit was brought up where
Andrew Schultz and the crew started
clowning on him a little bit and my was
not happy uh my's been challenging a lot
of people to boxing matches including
myself I uh somebody sent me this clip
I'm get the Honda 2002 I'm going to gym
I'm pting the gloves on and beat the
out of you man that's what we're
gonna do I have his phone number call
his ass on here you me call him call him
I'm calling watch him duck it
man go pick up bro hell no you a't going
to pick
up oh bad I'm just calling but not
picking up call again put the gloves on
back up what you got to say with your
fists man the amount of cope that you
guys give for Abba running away from his
own fights I don't know preach I've
never met him in my life we call him on
air two times we're calling this on air
no you you guys are a witness I told I
called Destiny we called him directly I
didn't even know fresh had his number
yeah I tagged him on Twitter remember
he's gonna duck it what happened you
don't you didn't answer like you I don't
have WhatsApp notifications on one and
two the funny thing is at the time day
we're calling I was at a birthday party
so here I am talking to ladies and I
guess these guys thought I'd be like I
hope fres fits calling let me find out
like
why why would I leave a birthday party
so I can answer a phone call from two
dweebs this just's like over 2 years old
people still talk like if it didn't
happen at first it's not going to happen
now just move on I guess Myron's been
sharing the fact that he been
training you been post on Twitter about
how you's been trading three times a
week ready for this boxing match the
time has passed if you think I'm going
to travel to Miami to go see friends and
family and then I'm going to take time
out of that to go spend time with you
you are Bugg it I feel like we're in a
playground you scared huh you scared you
want you want you you scared sure you
aing grown man out here using playground
insults to like trying to go to me into
something I have zero interest in it is
corny for grown men who want to be
leaders of other men to be out here
yelling emotionally stop being
a man screaming at people about how they
want to fight leave the fighting to the
fighters all these like corny ass
YouTubers and all these other people who
love to just talk about violence like
it's nothing it's corny you're just
posturing to make other people think you
look tough but the truth is your
business partner or your former
associate AUD who showed up at your
house broke in and has been finding you
in the streets what did you do when he
wanted to fight you and beat beat you up
when he said let's get in the ring
boxing gloves he walk up out of there
bro immediately after M was like Queen
watch out bro this about to come up on
us R right here with come up and M
blower like hey stop playing lose your
life come closer I'm about to blow your
back kept coming bro and and then
luckily the cop was right there we had
extra yeah fact here he he would legit
be right that crazy bro tried to
two different occasions really yes yes
that's what I'm trying to tell you like
bro I in public yes you don't want to
get in the ring with even though he
wants to get in a boxing ring with you
no you pull out the blicky at that time
what happened I thought you've been
training why don't you take that fight
it's because your ego couldn't handle
the thought of you losing so you've done
the calculation had you justify however
you want but the truth is it's because
you're a coward ain't that right by your
logic cuz I think there's a tweet from
you saying if you want to talk talk some
about people online you better get
ready to put on the boxing gloves and
get in the M ring so why aren't you
doing that you been talking these are
your words this is your Paradigm how
come you don't live by those
rules doesn't that make you the biggest
coward of all taking only fights that
you think you can
win oh you want to pull out a gun now
what happened here here's another person
rolling up on him in the UK I was come
to greet you from across the river I
don't know you man I don't know you Just
Bounce bro just bounce bro I don't know
BCE I don't know you bro
but huh come back over here come back
over here when he's gone when he's gone
when he's why did you have that same
energy for your y for HS Tik talki the
one who wanted to fight you been calling
you lived in your building let's be real
I saw him earlier yeah boys I saw him
earlier walking into the hotel with his
girl I was I was looking at him and the
he won't even look at me he's a little
that guy's a myON he looks
like he ego man no no do you know what
yeah you're probably watching this he
goes mad you're
little and I'll knock you out any day of
the week red pill this you would have
got bued at school I would bu you at
school no you now you want to take off
your shirt and fight somebody hold yo
hold me back hold me back man hold me
back hold me back hold me back yeah yeah
you're not holding hold me back hold me
back yeah yo dude what are you doing
what do you mean you supposed to hold me
back but you said you had a problem with
it no you're supposed to hold me back
okay my way me back yo yo yeah yeah you
so tough okay hold me back man you're
supposed to hold me back I think you
been working out I think you hand bro
you looking dumb right now bro my bed's
over there we can just lay down and
chill what the is wrong with you we on a
sports
team we on a sports
team we've been struggling together you
know working hard like let's getting B
hard pause like like just watch this
clown Behavior just watch this watch
this you coming back you come
back come back come back I you up right
now what's good what's good through
chill come through
and just think this guy used to be like
a federal agent what a
clown like the criteria to be a federal
a got to be trash and you know what's
funny is these guys always lar about oh
women are so emotional women are so look
at this clown he's in a foreign country
risking himself to go to jail in the UK
get his Visa banned for pretty much all
of Europe for what all
chill come on bro bro my come on dude
shout out to Fresh be like babyy come
back baby please baby baby come back
stop daddy why you going to fight Daddy
stop you don't look cool because you're
taking fights you think you can win it's
like what's his name sneo wants to fight
5' 6 Charlie I'm not calling him small
I'm saying he has no muscles yeah but
hit the gym Andrew Tate preaches getting
a better physique you really body
watching right now you're body shaming
but you can't fight Chad I don't want to
I'm not reacting to his stream this
guy's pissed me off and you could tell
him this I want to meet him in person
Angel Wallace you got me feeling some
type of way bro I ain't going to lie
those glasses this one little B I
challenge you you want to box me bro
let's do a 1 V one boxing match you say
I belong to the streets yeah I belong to
the streets we can rock this out on the
streets so we can do it in the ring bro
let's box you fat lying piece of sh I
would beat the out you Ethan Klein if
you said that about me you lie to my
name to my face let's get in the ring
stop talking about me and let's box
and then finally when Brandon Buckingham
is down to meet sneo he's there to box
him they're both similar size
mind you this Brandon Buckingham said he
wanted to run a train on sn's girl sneo
would now rather just sit at home and
tell jokes behind his computer I'd
rather just I'd rather sit at home and
yell at a camera tell jokes than you
know risk my manhood falling flat for
Branding branded Buckingham you know if
I lose the so these guys aren't Brave
they aren't courageous they aren't
strong they just want to appear strong
to Their audience they want to take
fights they think they could win I've
said this from the jump and I told this
to preach I think this whole fighting
is corny during this whole few
between I been preaching and fresh F
where we've been just basically clowning
on some of the stuff and the dumb
that they've said all you've done is
take lse you've just cost your business
millions of dollars you're getting
yourself demonetized over the dumbest
is that how a leader operates is
that what you want to teach everybody
hey guys watching don't be strategic
don't be smart just say whatever you
want do whatever you want and lose a
bunch of money wow that's great
financial advice that's a great example
to set you guys are grown people with
networks in the Millions talking about
putting on gloves to settle your issues
like it settles anything what example
are you setting for people all your
followers are going to get boxing rings
with people they have disputes with too
just stop it uh but you can carry on
Yelling you can say I'm scared you can
say it doesn't bother me imagine trying
to appeal to a bunch of strangers and be
like n I'm a brave man I need y'all to
know so I'm going get when you fight
somebody at the drop of the dime cuz
they said some words to you so like
let's say they call you a coward they
call you they say they want a box or
whatever you're essentially giving them
control over your mental state and your
actions like today it's these guys what
happens when the next person says
something about my family I got to go
fight them too what about the next
person that has an issue with them I got
to go fight them too like it becomes a
NeverEnding cycle these kinds of things
I'm not saying don't defend your family
somebody puts hands on your people
that's a different thing but you got to
understand like there's not a shortage
of people who are going to say crazy
things online are you going to
constantly react to everybody in the way
they want it's not because somebody
calls you something that you then have
to go and immediately start get it's not
a reasonable way to handle yourself
online what do you want to say
say
um well first and foremost I never
challenged them I accepted this
difference they challenged
me and when I accepted there was nothing
on the line we try to contact you
nothing Duds I said both of y'all both
of y'all the one that initially said it
and you and for some reason now all of a
sudden you want to take him
it's me you targeted why all of a sudden
you don't have a problem with me when I
initially accepted you see how
weird that is how corny that is and he
thinks it's corny because you even you
didn't call you even call me out on on
cam I told you offline you told me yeah
we were filming and you told me offline
and yes yes and you're you're right but
but just just on that point the thing I
said was like listen it's not my place
to tell somebody how they want to defend
their family or wife so that's your
thing me personally I just don't like it
when I see grown men talking about they
want to fight to settle disputes but I'm
it's not my place to tell you so you're
your own person I understand what you're
saying but you you you also said that it
was corny you said that to me too and
it's and it's and it's fine and I and I
agreed that's not my point I didn't
think it was corny initially said I said
it corny a year after you know like a
year after but is still talking
about it it's like if y'all not going to
fight at the beginning just stop
bringing it up 100% 100% 100% you're
right no no but but you're right but
you're right it was a year after to put
the proper context absolutely it was a
year after but you initially you you and
your partner actually did that you
called me out it's with me that you had
a
problem he never wanted to do it he like
even when I brought it up he didn't even
know that was going on you could watch
the video again you're like wait what
what's going on what I remember that
wait wait what I was like yeah if y'all
want to talk come back in the
studio we'll talk about it or we could
box about it too cuz I'm in the gym now
you feel me feeling feeling nice right
now the box or preach bro Bo bro so you
know what come back to to Miami let's
box it
out how about
that and later on in the video you're
saying that you want to box with
me sort of happen that I'm going to be
in the US next week you want to
do this let's go both of you I'll
be in us next week hold up hold
up I'll let's go we'll put gloves on cuz
not only this that's why I have a
problem now you talk about my wife
this preaches married prior to a
beluga well somewhere and y'all
talking and you talk about my
country old said that he was about to
send me on a boat to my country to Haiti
yeah cool next week I'll be in I'll be
in the states I'll drop by youring
Studios you know where it is give me the
address I'll be right there we'll put
gloves on it'll be legal I know Florida
liar I take one then I take the other
one listen I'm not here to have people
fight Advocate but preach you're your
own man I was the one that was willing I
was the one that was let's go and when
we contact you you said nothing h a
partner as well didn't respond saw the
messages didn't respond both of you now
you're going to switch it to Abba that's
fine that's cool that's what we know
that you don't want none of that and if
video you said I don't really so much
have a problem with preach and then you
call other people
coward my boy cuz that's what you is a
boy sit down sit that one down also
think about this think about this
um that being
said there's a way that you can get with
a sugar and I'll say this I person like
this is just my take on it like black
men and their egos when it it comes to
online stuff is especially pompous like
the amount of time I see black graders
talking about I'm going to box you I'm
going to catch you in these streets and
I'm like bro you got like 500,000
subscribers like what are you doing you
going to catch a case and risk your
whole you're going to stop the money
that CES your family to do what and I'm
not saying these guys asking for a
boxing match or whatever is the exact
same thing what I'm trying to say is
you're inherently telling your audience
to solve these kinds of issues with
violence are you going to be the man at
your house with that kind of attitude
are you going to be able to take care
and provide with your family because
you're out here challenging people to
boxing matches you think that good to
employers when you're talking to people
and you're like yeah I challenge these
people to fights like it's clown
Behavior I think we already went over
the fact that like we would never do
that on in the streets that was never
the purpose that was never the point if
that was to happen but even if I see you
in the I'm not going to do that we're
about to do it the proper way legal way
but you didn't want that so yo but even
doing it the legal way what does it
settle it it settles it settles nothing
it settles nothing I got yeah and I'mma
tell you right now it's really just ego
100% And I'm not saying that you just
you only have ego yes you do but it was
me too on my side it was ego
too go ahead what do you mean oh me yeah
me responding to that was ego it was
100% ego it was me being heard about
different things about the the different
thing in the past and stuff like that
and that just just brought all that
back up what you you give us an example
or you don't have to talk about it if
you don't want to but no it's just how I
was treated and when I was a kid and how
yeah how I was treated when I was a kid
how people used to clim me when I was a
kid and stuff like that it's like I
thought I overcame all that and I it was
finally over and I have this ass mother
doing that as well like okay you
going to get it for everybody you going
to get it for everybody that's still ego
yeah that's still ego there's better
ways to act there's better ways to do
stuff like that you know what I mean and
they said no they knew it's just the
switch up is just weird to me I don't
know why it switched to you about you
you know why it's because he thinks he
can win and listen here's the thing if
you've ever been in fights and loss even
if you've been insulted in front of
people like especially when your ego's
really caught up into it you replay that
moment and then you replay what you
would do differently it's like that
Kevin Hart beam where the parents says
something to the kid and the kid starts
pacing around in his room
was F
yeah you
yeah that's this guy in box that's why
he's been training because he has his
vision in his head of how he's going to
fix the past um clown that he's received
and it's not just a him thing like you
see this with our people all the time a
says something on Facebook
they take the insult they imagine
everyone laughing at them then they
start ramping themselves up the next
time they catch the dude they pull out a
weapon they do whatever it's that ego
that makes you drive it drives you crazy
like I can't I can't sumach this shame
if I beat this person up then
even if you get that you get the
temporary boost you get the dopamine
from people calling you a big dude but
the truth is you're still the same
miserable ass person you were before no
respects you cuz you're a
you're a you're sitting in
this chest like well yeah just NW workk
with millionaires I don't know if I'm
going to make it oh never every's going
to become millionaire you're a
what the is wrong with you you're going
to have the mindset that I have I will
not fuing lose these two in Canada try
to destroy us guess what happens we
became even stronger from that I'm
like a say it you hit me I live
through the battle and I get stronger
after the fact now we're number one best
podcast in the world that's such a nerd
can you say I'm like a Sayan yo did
he just call himself some kind of DBC
character bro you cannot y whatever when
I told you about that fantasy you
shall not you cannot tell me that that's
not nerd I got in the hyperbolic Time
Chamber and now I'm ready to fight
somebody weaker than me godam if you're
saying go fight a
y That's what I'm saying with you that's
what I'm saying with you yeah yeah yeah
go be Goku go be Vegeta and what
happened to Goku he got beat up a bunch
of times he died a few times he died
died a few times yeah but we ain't got
no Dragon Balls those two clowns tried
to destroy us and theying fail I want
your opponents to fear you have the fear
of God if I ever run this
he's going to beat the shadow me that's
what I want because you have the fierce
tenacity that no one can no one your
voice is breaking my guy these two in
Canada God they wanted to fight me
Canadians
make no one let you fear you you're a
man you're the prize my God welcome to
the Crusty
Crab you understand stop your SE in this
chat tell me some dumb about I
don't know where I stand I don't know if
I can do it yes you can stop being a
b man that's where I want y'all to be
where everyone is scared of you they
cannot stop you cuz they know if I get
in this Mother's way he's going to run
me over and he's going to going to
destroy me in the process no one can
stop you that's what I want you guys to
have man hearing another grown man huff
and puff while they say my name is
PA that is mad weird energy I'm un PR yo
what you been doing I'm going to keep
laughing at you there's nothing you
could really do about it cuz I think
dudes who huff and puffing scream and
they're very loud they're generally the
biggest jokes in
society and the fact that you spend your
whole time on your podcast calling women
emotional women can't control themselves
women are not to be you seem like a
liability my friend you seem like you
can't control your emotions whatsoever
what happened to being stoic to
controlling yourself you can't do it so
again another one of these alpha male
podcasts these red pill dweebs can't
hold the frame that they preach their
audiences to they just scream and they
get upset and they take a lot of lse
think about this in the last 2 years all
these guys have done is cost themselves
all the opportunities that they've spent
their whole careers building for
themselves congratulations you played
yourself and you're probably going to
lose way more down the line because you
can't control your emotions so put a
time stamp on it you going to say Abba
predicted it uh these not
going to last much longer by the way we
got a Discord Please Subscribe real
Alpha men have a Discord and uh Reddit
subscribe that voice crack that voice
crack where he try to be the mainest
dude possible his voice betrayed
him